so i was just um i was just conversing
with my friend edgar here
about well
just how intimate and just how generous
uh it is
to offer your
inner world to offer your mind to a
filmmaker when you watch
a movie there can be few acts
of such
submission we are basically
allowing
this film
to
become our mental content and
in turn
to become
us
my friend was saying he once watched
he binge watched
an entire all the uh
all the films of stanley kubrick stanley
kubrick of course is known for directing
2001 a space odyssey clockwork
metal orange
full metal jacket
you know a lot of impactful films that
get
well that have gotten under the skin of
our collective unconscious we we we
speak about
stanley kubrick in almost mythological
terms and i think the reason we do so uh
is unsurprising because he is a
mythological referent for us because
those of us who have seen his movies
have therefore been to those
inter-psychic places with him we have
allowed our minds to be taken possession
of and we have entertained realms and
worlds that he has concocted we have we
have
within us his worlds have been disclosed
to enter into a relationship with a film
is for our very consciousness to meet
itself right our very consciousness
meets a version of its own process and
so a movie is really a mirror that
reveals us to our selves it just happens
to be conducted by this kind of interci
conductor known as a filmmaker and so
in a sense when we give ourselves to
these movies and to these filmmakers we
are
experiencing a kind of state of
transcendence in which we uh become
archetypal and our mental content
becomes archetypal and we enter into the
collective
a kind of collected a collective
consciousness an archetypal
consciousness and and it's
it's a real place that has its own
ontological pasture and the reason i
believe that to be true is because those
of us that have enjoyed the same films
now have a kind of kinship right terence
mckenna said find the others you find
other people who are enthusiastic about
those same movies and when you see each
other there's a twinkle in each other's
eye and there's a mutual recognition
there's a kind of inside baseball and a
kind of secret handshake that says oh
yeah you watch stanley kubrick films or
you watch steven spielberg films or
you're a fan of james cameron i mean
it's the reason these life worlds are
rich and real within us it's a reason
why things like comic con have the rabid
followings that they do because these
are life worlds fully constructed life
worlds fully fully imagineered and and
and sort of exteriorized inter-psychic
life worlds that we can all pay
visitation to and so when you think
about things like gaming and virtual
reality these are just deepening
examples of the same thing they're inter
psychic life worlds that we all enter
with and into together and they are real
they are spaces of mind but they are
real right the imagination is real and
these are examples of
i guess like like they are
inter-subjective constructs that allow
us to un
sort of that to to
they kind of allow us to un
to kind of unfold in
right when we when when we mate
with a film there is a communion and
there is a moment when enveloped in its
narrative trance
we start to have a real experience under
imaginary circumstances this is known as
the dramatic catharsis when it peaks by
assuming the viewpoint of the character
on screen which is a very real phenomena
we enter a kind of liminal waking dream
that is not burdened by the euclidean
mid space meet space and so to that end
cinema is metaphysical and reflects
mankind's historical drive to make
manifest his consciousness outside of
his mind in front of his eyes a place
where we can intersubjectively go into
and and and sort of become sort of
become one mind in right it's a shared
experience of inter-subjectivity where
all of us essentially and functionally
for that moment at least become
one
and
that's an amazing thing because when we
see ourselves reflected in cinema and in
the work of these great directors seeing
ourselves
reflected is is a sort of reaffirming is
it it has a reaffirming function that we
bring back with us into the default
world
right the power of that mythological
realization is something that imbues
itself into our normal waking state so
that we meet the world with a little
more grace and a little more wisdom and
a little more humility perhaps as well
and a little more knowing
so that's why movies are so wonderful
that's why watching them is such an
intimate act of communion and such a
wonderful offering but it's also a
highly recommended thing cinema
ultimately is a kind of church
it's a church